this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
what's up everyone michael here and
today i'm gonna do a philosophical
reaction to the show that dared to ask
what if tupac has been alive in
amsterdam the entire time pretty sure
that's
tupac
what i'm talking about season three of
atlanta now in the first two seasons
they use things like surrealism
absurdism a little bit of existentialism
to explore possibility contained in
seemingly impossible situations i.e that
an aging weed dealer could become an
international rap superstar that a
college dropout living in a storage
space could be the manager for that
superstar or that you can barter your
way to wealth in any situation
actually let me get this sword man but
in season three they seem to be
exploring the opposite perspective which
is that sometimes situations that seem
like they're brimming with pure
possibility actually are riddled with
impossibility and really finite limits
and in particular that these
impossibilities can stem from things
like racism colonialism and its deep
history and these things are so
ingrained into the fabric of reality and
society as to make them unavoidable i
want to check out just a couple of
episodes from this season to see how
some philosophy might help us make sense
of what's going on and might help us
understand the larger implications of
what went down this season so welcome to
philosopher reacts to atlanta season
three and spoilers ahead for the show
atlanta which we're watching obviously
but before we dive in i want to talk
about this video sponsor surfsharkvpn
surfsharkvpn secure protocols and
uncrackable encryption keep your
personal information safe as you
navigate the web now one of my favorite
things about using a secure vpn like
surf shark is that it helps me avoid
price gouging it's actually pretty
simple because surf shark hides my
location websites can't inflate their
prices based on that location and that
can add up to significant savings
especially when shopping for things like
plane tickets which are very expensive
right now another of surfshark's perks
is secure file sharing because all of
your internet traffic is encrypted your
downloads remain safe and secure so go
ahead download every image that comes up
when you search for kierkegaard and
nietzsche but in bikini sipping
cocktails and no one will ever know not
that i've ever done that
or made those images
one subscription covers all of your
favorite devices from your laptop xbox
and android all the way to your amazon
fire stick and beyond including options
for apps like chrome and firefox so get
started today by clicking the link in
the description and using the promo code
wisecrack when you do you can get
surfsharkvpn for 83 off plus three extra
months for free go to surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show okay so it was hard to pick
from all the episodes this season i want
to start with episode four it's called
the big payback which shows us what
happens when doug from the hangover
movies starts a new life in atlanta far
from his sociopathic friends
note that he's perusing the snacks
oh he's gonna grab the cookies he's
gonna grab some cookies he's gonna grab
some cookies
oh boy all right your order wow now the
ball's rolling oh he's gonna go give it
back
oh he's happy with himself
he's eating his crime cookies he's so
happy about it okay
this is important you have a black man
suing josh beckford an early investor in
tesla due to the fact that his ancestors
were enslaved by relatives of mr
beckford's that human capital and profit
can be directly linked to the financials
of the company so i do think there's
merit and he could win the lawsuit
not could win did win mr umbaye did win
the lawsuit a scenario that seemed look
on his face right there
that subtle head shake i like what's
going on here and i think that the
cookie scene is interesting right
because we see this character get away
with stealing something without
consequences and being happy that he
stole it without consequences we then
cut to a scene where he's in the car
with his daughter and we hear about a
trial taking place where black person
sues an early investor in tesla because
his ancestors were enslaved by his
relatives but this brings up this
question right of how much our
identities and our own sense of
responsibility is tied to our past and
our history so if we think about this in
a classic existentialist framework
there's this idea that we're born
completely free right unshaped by
external or historical forces and we and
we alone are responsible for our choices
but not for those of our parents our
grandparents our
great-great-grandparents and so on right
this is why sartre very early on says
existence precedes essence meaning that
what we do shapes who we are and there's
not this thing of like who we are it's
pre-programmed it's determining who we
are sart also says that man is condemned
to be free but here the show seems to be
starting to pose this question is what
responsibility do we bear for choices
made by past generations particularly if
we benefit in seemingly unfair ways from
those choices this brings up this
question of freedom versus facticity so
we think about freedom philosophically
for me at least i think about the
ability to self-determine so if i have
freedom i have the ability to
reflect decide on a course of action and
self-determine that action but there's
this other thing called facticity and
facticity describes elements of my
existence that i'm sort of born into a
martin heidegger used the term
throneness to talk about this right so
when i'm thrown into existence i didn't
choose who my parents were i didn't
choose where i was born we don't choose
our hair color when we're born in
history our class status or just tossed
into existence by two people who had sex
facticity describes all of those things
that we're born into that are outside of
our control right right here they're
bringing up this question of like
are we responsible
for that facticity right are we purely
free
or is it the case that people could be
held responsible
for the actions of their ancestors and
how that affected
their lives and obviously here they're
connecting that to the idea of
reparations which is the idea that
america owes financial reparations to
the ancestors of enslaved people who
again people who were enslaved were
thrown into that situation right they
did not freely will or determine to be
that we kind of have those twin
questions right here who is responsible
for what and what is the limit of
responsibility when we look at history
our main character of course ends up
getting sued by someone because his
ancestors enslaved hers and she wants
some money for it and he's not handling
it well so he reaches out to some
co-workers for their opinions hey man
how are you doing pretty good
his whole like demeanor has changed now
that he's on the other side of things
uh i know it's a crazy time and
everything
and uh
i'm i really don't know what to do
um
no thanks
i'm just a guy
you know trying to get by
and i feel like this woman is
harassing me
i just don't know what to do yeah that
whole notion of like i'm just a guy
trying to get by
really seems like it's him trying to
disconnect himself
from his history and the way he's
benefited from it the only thing you can
do is say you were wrong
and give her as much money as you can
she'll probably want to meet with you
101
cut you down a bit i just don't know
what to do
honestly my advice you gotta fight that
man it's like when you're a kid and one
parent says something you don't want to
hear so you go to the other parent
hoping they'll say that basically what
he's doing here okay so we're sticking
with this question of responsibility
right this guy seems to be making the
argument that he bears no personal
responsibility to the woman suing him
and thus he shouldn't owe her any money
in the present which builds on this
existential assumption that he's only
responsible for his freely willed
actions and that his identity isn't tied
to anything other than a sort of pure
ontological freedom now the philosopher
louis gordon coined the term black
existentialism gordon takes the
existentialist concept of bad faith and
bad faith describes what happens when we
basically try to treat ourselves as
objects without freedom rather than
subjects who have freedoms sartre
uses the famous example of a waiter
that's kind of performing the identity
of waiter in a cafe that's in his book
being in nothingness but gordon takes
this concept of bad faith and uses it to
better understand racism now gordon says
the sartre imposition raises the
question of racism as a form of bad
faith since it is a form of evasion of
human reality so this means that in
acting like
institutional historical racism doesn't
have tangible effects in reality white
people like our guy in the episode are
performing that type of bad faith when
he's huddled you know with his
co-workers it seems like everyone's
performing that same type of bad faith
like they're evading the reality of
their history of the country of their
situation and i want to jump to later in
the episode where this all gets laid out
there a lot more clearly marshall is now
decamped to a hotel because in his eyes
his life is falling apart a bit and he
makes a friend at the hotel park
two days ago i had a good life and now
i'm being [ __ ] by some [ __ ] that i
didn't even do so the outline there and
he says he's being [ __ ] by some [ __ ]
that he didn't even do
it's still that idea that he's like
disconnected
from history in that way and shouldn't
bear responsibility maybe it's only
right
e
we don't deserve
this well what do they deserve we were
treating slavery
as if it were a mystery yeah he's
basically saying that
something to investigate they're not
treating
the history of slavery as a real
material historical thing that actually
happened so now you're away you're
separated from your wife
she's taking your kid god this is
intense now she has to be raised without
a father she has to build wealth and
success from the ground up right
similar to the position we put them in
we're gonna be okay your daughter's
gonna be okay
the curse
lifted from her that's interesting when
he says the curse has been lifted from
her it's sort of like by taking
responsibility for that history
his daughter would be untethered from
that we're getting at that fundamental
question of how we relate our freedom to
historical responsibility and i've
talked about sart already but it's
important to know that sartre actually
changed his position from his early
existentialism to his later position he
started to doubt the type of pure
existentialism which is kind of similar
to marshall's vibe here in which social
and political history aren't tied to our
free existence and i think during the
time where start changed his mind he
also got really influenced by marxism
and the work of people like franz fanon
now in an interview that took place in
1969 sartre was asked to describe the
relationship between his early and late
work and during the interview sark
recalls himself writing that whatever
his circumstances and wherever the site
a man is always free to be a traitor or
not and then sartre tells the
interviewer when i read this i said to
myself it's incredible that i actually
believed that and i think we kind of see
both sides of that at the hotel bar here
marshall feels like he shouldn't have to
bear responsibility for something that
he didn't do his friend ernest is
basically saying no we can't abstract
ourselves from a real history we are
tied up in this whether you like it or
not when he says confession isn't
absolution which means you can't just
like my bad racism away you know he's
saying it has real historical material
effects and ernest's position is similar
to sart's later synthesis of
existentialism with historical
materialism now historical materialism
is the idea
that history is shaped by material
conditions material activities economic
reality history isn't just shaped by
ideas but what happens and in books like
search for method and critique of
dialectical reason start gets into this
and kind of i guess has his existential
cake while eating his historical
materialism too now when this guy ernest
ties together historical facticity and
economic reality he's arguing against
the type of racist bad faith that we saw
in the work of lewis gordon and he's
operating in good faith in a sense
because he's acknowledging that you know
things like slavery and colonialism have
absolutely shaped the material and
economic reality of lots of people some
for better some for much worse and that
his subject group has benefited from
this now there's a quote from france
fanon that i like here fanon says
genuine disalienation will have been
achieved only when things in the most
materialist sense have resumed their
rightful place and i think what phenom
is saying there is that ending like a
racist disalienation isn't just about
thinking better ideas or agreeing to be
better as people but about materially
transforming conditions and earnest in
this clip seems to be saying that
economic justice reparations
is part of what it means to take
responsibility you know what he does
after that is a little much we're we're
not going to show that you can watch it
for yourself but i think that episode
really opens up a lot of interesting
things you might have noted however that
the episode doesn't feature any of the
characters that we think of when we
think of atlanta so i want to check out
another episode where we're going to see
all of our friends again okay so now i
want to check out the episode called
white fashion and i want to look at both
darius and paper boy's journeys in this
episode so let's start by watching
darius's arc in the episode where he
experiences the struggle of trying to
share his culinary culture with a white
lady who at first seems genuinely
curious and interested so let's get
started there are you niger
yes i'm nicer oh couldn't tell your hair
is so
weeble
so this seems like a nice moment river
state ejo darius is just sharing
his culture with someone else he's
connecting with this restaurant owner
this is great oh i love her
i need to get her business card
there is a lot of growth potential this
story gets weird right when she says
there's a lot of growth potential
it's like that shift from looking at a
culture in an appreciative way and now
seeing growth potential i mean i like
fish but boneless fishes is yours i'm
working and even that that she has to
like shazam to know the music
okay it seems like we're getting more of
that type of bad faith that gordon talks
about in so much
as this woman doesn't really seem to be
considering the cultural significance of
darius being originally from nigeria
what it means to be at this restaurant
experiencing another culture especially
a culture that was under british
colonial power until the 1960s sartre
said and he said this about reading
fenon he said have the courage to read
it primarily because it'll make you feel
ashamed and shame as mark said is a
revolutionary feeling i think in a sense
in this scene we don't see a lot of
shame in this woman and that lack of
shame seems to allow her to just see
everything in this restaurant as a
product or a possibility and when sartre
makes this point in his preface to
finance book you know he seems to be
saying that like the effects of western
colonialism of slavery should make
people feel ashamed because that shame
could lead them to breaking that cycle
of you know racist bad faith and
changing things i want to now jump
to see what happens it's not good we'll
just watch it really quickly though yeah
so here he goes back to the restaurant
it's closed down yo
darius
over here the white lady is there
she has started a nigerian
food truck so she relocated and where's
mimi
i don't know we actually never exchanged
info uh
what's in it
it's a peach barbecue reduction and
chunks
i call it the darius because you're from
georgia she even named a dish after him
so like we said before um there's some
irony here because the country of
nigeria was colonized by britain and now
this british woman has basically
colonized a nigerian restaurant you know
in the same book i just quoted um where
sartre was talking about phenom but none
himself says when i look for man in
european lifestyles and technology i see
a constant denial of man an avalanche of
murders i think similar to the bad faith
of black existentialism fenon is here
pointing out that when european
lifestyle and technology deny the
humanity of black people in their
culture it allows them to
instrumentalize them and use them as
they would any other product or
resource and in this case this woman
doesn't seem to be recognizing the
humanity of a nigerian woman and her
restaurant and her culture she sees a
concept that can be used to create
profit for herself and of course darius
seems to be realizing this all in real
time and this is from sart's preface
once again he says you who are so
liberal so humane who take the love of
culture to the point of affectation you
pretend to forget that you have colonies
or massacres are committed in your name
and i think when sartre here talks about
loving a culture to the point of
affectation he's getting at this idea
that people love cultural products or
aspects of culture while conveniently
forgetting once again kind of in that
bad faith way that massacres have been
committed in the name of those people's
countries in this case you know we see
that with this woman who's from a
culture that colonized nigeria
now like micro colonizing a nigerian
restaurant now while all this is
happening in the same episode paperboy
is having a similar experience on a
larger scale and it involves a french
fashion company okay so this is
presumably
a gift
to that guy's grandkid from the fashion
designer
okay it's a jersey that says central
park five many of you know that the
central park five were a group of young
black men in new york who were falsely
accused of murdering a woman they were
exonerated but they spent time in jail
it was very very bad and now we're using
that trauma and pain to make clothes for
presumably very rich people we want to
apologize to the community properly okay
um with your help and now the same
fashion company
wants
paperboy
to be one of the faces of their
apologies
for
for doing a racism you're not worried
about
you know what the streets think
the streets
ah what man [ __ ] the streets man i shot
[ __ ] you trying to tell me that you uh
you wouldn't take any of these uh free
designer gifts and we're seeing this
tension right where
paper boy is taking advantage of the
situation to get
some designer clothes
and earn is asking the question on the
board for at least five years you know
can we do something more here then i
start my own program help out black
entrepreneurs and business owners like a
reinvesting your hood campaign ern here
is encouraging paperboy to take
advantage of the situation and do
something positive and use his subject
position as a you know internationally
famous rapper to get this fashion
company to do something to empower urban
communities and to even you know build
his own foundation there's a phenomenon
quote that i think applies a little bit
here where fenan says for europe for
ourselves for humanity comrades we must
make a new start develop a new way of
thinking and endeavor to create a new
man fanon thought it was possible to
create a new world and a new humanism
and by by a new humanism he means like a
universal conception of humanity and he
thinks we do this by first rethinking
the type of sort of western humanism
associated with the western
philosophical tradition and you know
white european humans so rather than
just
making the category human or humanism
this white european human thing he wants
it to apply to everyone but of course
earns ideas here assume a world in which
a multinational fashion company would
have a genuine interest in helping use
their capital to directly invest in
black communities and we see how this
goes a little bit when we get to the
press conference where paperboy has to
apologize for racism so let's let's cut
there really quick hmm
with your parisian
paperboy
after this is racism over okay so she
just asked paper boi
said paper boi after this is racism over
um
no
obviously
i mean look like look at the boring
industry right uh
is that with our new initiative
we believe racism will be done by 2024.
he said racism will be done
by 20
24. after that experience and seeing the
press conference safer boy wants to sort
of listen to earn's advice so he comes
up with a pitch i just got this idea
about black people making money you know
what i'm saying and putting them black
dollars in black hands and then we just
support black businesses right because
if you take them dollars and put them
back in your neighborhood your
neighborhood will grow so i figure we
just call it the reinvest in your hood
campaign right think about it reinvest
in your hood
reinvest
in your hood reinvesting
okay so there
again we see paperboy
truly wanting to do something positive
create some type of change now here's
the ad that the fashion brand comes up
with reinvest in your food
think about it because if you take them
dollars and put them back in your
neighborhood your neighborhood will grow
yo
we got cowboys we got
kids and goats we're all from some hood
we have we're all from some hood old
white ladies okay so this ad seems to do
precisely what someone like fenon was
worried about right it takes you know a
sort of white liberal humanism and says
that black people count but so do rich
white ladies because they're all from
some hood sartre grew more cynical in
his later work in the critique of
dialectical reason and sartre argued
that well human freedom is capable of
rising up and trying to change the world
and he calls these moments apocalypses
that these movements of freedom and
equality run up against institutions so
those could be states governments
businesses and here it seems like
paperboy's attempt to use his freedom in
a certain situation to do something
positive was met with the power of the
institution that is a fashion company
and a marketing ecosystem in which
inclusion only matters when it's
including new consumers who could
potentially buy their clothes and usart
says demanding yet denying the human
condition makes for an explosive
contradiction and it seems like that's
what's happening here they're both
demanding and denying the human
condition in this case for black people
and people affected by their very messed
up ad campaign so the last clip i want
to look at you know we have the
aftermath of paperboy seeing the
commercial that the fashion company made
i know what the [ __ ] the red cross is
it's the worst one i mean this is
intense here in this scene because you
see
paper boi alfred
kind of like losing losing hope
look ask yourself this
why
why would a company make a project that
would teach black people to stop buying
their products and reinvest in their own
why would they fund their own demise he
says why would they fund their own
demise look i told you i've been doing
the social justice thing a long time
something about that phrasing i've been
doing this social justice thing here
this character is basically telling
paperboy that the type of change he
wants is impossible in the current
system think back to sart's notion of
institutions right in this case the
institution of the fashion industry and
capitalism are stopping what paperboy
wants to do in a sense we see the limits
of the optimism we find in fenon's work
and this brings up a concept called
afro-pessimism which is a philosophy
attributed to the work of frank
wilderson and unlike fenon's call for
new humanism that would move past
colonization and racism wilderson
doesn't think that racism is is fixable
he says at one point blackness is
coterminous with slaveness and in a new
yorker review they actually compare his
position to phenons and say that for
wilderson venon's cup is too full other
previously colonized peoples are indeed
human but not black people one of the
bleakest aspects of afro-pessimist
thought is its denial that there is any
meaningful analogy between blacks and
other non-whites and this is all very
intense sounding but for someone like
wilderson the issues that play here the
legacies of things like slavery and
colonization and anti-black racism are
baked too deeply into society into
western capitalism to just change
especially not via a marketing campaign
now i think then with that in mind we
could read this conversation that
paperboy has as
this idea that like a a system built on
capitalism and colonization and slavery
is never going to have space for real
black liberation built into it so the
best thing that could happen is that you
know some rich companies funnel some
money into some non-profit so some
people can do some good stuff with that
and in this episode it seems like we
kind of go from a more
phenom inspired
optimism humanism to
a more afro-pessimistic position a lot
of the work of wilderson now in this
episode both paperboy and darius run up
against the limits of freedom and their
own existential control darius sees how
an earnest and seemingly kind attempt to
share a bit of his culture with a new
friend can backfire when that person
just views that culture as a product to
be repackaged in a food truck and then
paperboy runs up against the
institutions of capitalism and
consumerism and realizes that no amount
of good intentions can make those
systems less corrupt okay so it seems
that in this season by introducing a
level of harsh impossibility into the
lives of its characters the show is
trying to explore a sense of finitude in
the world the idea that there's some
things that we can't change and maybe
that will never be able to change
whether it be matters of racial identity
the histories of colonialism and
capitalism or even our individual
identities in doing this the show is
following a bit of a post-existentialist
philosophical agenda right with sartre
we're seeing how a seemingly limitless
existential freedom can run up against
the limits of institutions with phenom
we're exploring the alienation and
unconscious violence that colonialism
and racism have cooked into society and
asking whether or not a new humanism is
possible and with wilderson and the
afro-pessimist the show seems to be
asking if these problems can never be
solved and considering that maybe this
type of racism is a permanent feature of
western culture and of course it's kind
of fitting that this all takes place
against the backdrop of europe a place
that in one sense seems more forward and
progressive than america but is also
directly haunted by the colonial
violence of its past do let us know what
you think in the comments and as always
if you enjoyed this video like subscribe
ring that bell thank you so much to our
patrons and if you haven't checked it
out in a while give our patreon page a
glance because we've got some great new
stuff going on there and remember to
check out our new stream wisecrack live
that happens right here every thursday
at 11am pacific as always thank you so
much for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you